Here is a specific example of how
retention affects in-app purchases.
This graph shows the amount of
in-app purchases by the hour for
the top 50 games in the Amazon App Store
right after they've been downloaded.
So, this gives us a good idea of
what in-net purchases look like for
successful games over time.
Look at the initial 24 hours.
There's a big spike in in-app purchases.
The first day is often where
players make the most purchases.
In fact, most games make about
18% of all their in-app sales
from players buying items
within the first day.
But that leaves 82% of in-app
sales coming from players
who continue to buy over time.
So even though this initial spike is
impressive, these smaller purchases that
stay consistent are even more important
for your game to continue making money.
These regular purchases also mean
that players like your game.
They are playing your game everyday and
willing to pay for it bit by bit.
The bottom line is that the longer
someone stays engaged and
plays your game,
the more money it will make.